américa es la región más afectada por el
coronavirus en el mundo con un total de
40 millones de casos y casi un millón de
muertes atraviesa el peor momento de la
pandemia según la organización
panamericana de la salud en que las
ubica no sólo en la última semana 2,5
millones de personas se contagiaron por
el cob y de 19 en nuestras regiones
la cifra de casos de semanal más elevada
desde que el virus alcanzado en nuestras
costas por primera vez a eeuu encabeza
la lista con 23 millones de contagios y
más de 380.000 fallecidos le sigue
brasil con 8 millones 256 mil casos y
con 205 mil muertes por kobe 19 es el
segundo con más fallecidos en el mundo
después del gigante sudamericano las
naciones con más contagios son colombia
argentina y méxico en colombia que tiene
un millón 381 mil contagios el
presidente iván duque extendió la
emergencia sanitaria hasta el 28 de
febrero mientras se enfrenta una
controversia por su lento proceso de
adquisición de vacunas
hoy quiero informarle al país que ese
decreto de aislamiento selectivo con
distanciamiento individual responsable
se extiende hasta el 28 de febrero de la
mano con la emergencia sanitaria y
méxico es el país con la mayor
mortalidad del mundo 135 mil personas de
las 1 millón 556.000 positivas han
fallecido es decir el 87 por ciento
otros países como cuba con 500 contagios
diarios o perú con una huelga de médicos
indefinida vive también contextos
extremos según la organización
panamericana de la salud prácticamente
todas las naciones de las américas han
visto una aceleración y están
desbordadas por el cob y 19